who's telling lies who is in the line of
fire and did the Pussycats bring all the
boys to the yard all that and so much
more on this episode of Sweetwater
secrets
[Music]
hey vixens I'm Lana Galera and welcome
to the after-show for chapter 15 night
Hawks so if you haven't already watched
episode 201 leave right now we're about
to spoil everything
so go come back afterwards but you got
to go all right guys now it is ladies
night on Sweetwater secrets and I'll be
bringing you exclusive behind-the-scenes
scoop from Camilla Mendez Lilly
Reinhardt
Madeline patch and Ashley Marie so get
excited but first it's time to kick
things off with the top headlines of the
night in the blue and gold breakdown top
headline of the night the masked man
attacks again
now while midge and moose were trying to
have an oh so romantic date night of
getting high on jingle jangle and
fooling around in their car high school
our mysterious masked man fired multiple
shots into the car now no word on if
they're going to survive but only a
storm trooper would miss the mark on a
shot that close
next up Archie's got a gun now after
spending the entire episode and a
panicked in paranoid state
Archie finally found the one thing that
would let him rest easy a gun something
tells me this is going to backfire bad
pun intended and decide no can someone
please explain to me how ill tyndall II
just has an extra pistol laying around
damn till tender shady as hell and
lastly mama Lodge is a big fat liar
after Veronica confronted Hyrum about
the heinous letter he wrote in season
one that was threatening her mom
Hermione shocked us all when she told us
no she actually wrote the letter no it
turns out his lies on top of lies on top
of lies your father didn't write this
letter I did now here's what cami had to
tell me about Hermione's hidden
intentions we're seeing so much tension
between Hermione and between Veronica
what do you think that's about like why
are we seeing so much sad too because
season one they were like such a team
yes and now with the addition of Hyrum I
think Hermione just kind of switched and
she's on Team Hyrum and Veronica doesn't
really feel like my team has her back
anymore and truly Veronica does not
trust Hermione
so I think now it's a matter of finding
out what Hermione's intentions are once
again your loyalty knows no bounds I
don't know Hermione you're being pretty
sketchy alright guys what do you think
about Hermione's actions shout it out in
the comments below and let me know what
you think moving on to seven seconds in
heaven now this episode was not nearly
as sexually charged as the season 2
premiere but we did get some super-sweet
bug head moments including this dreamy
diner kiss
I'm sure they're just here to enjoy pop
some world-class burgers and service now
since we were lacking a little bit in
the romance department in Nighthawks
here's an update from liliane bug head
season to future
I know fans are concerned about tensions
brewing between Betty and Jughead
what are what are your thoughts on on
that I mean I've been saying kind of as
a tease basically as jugheads on the
south side and she's on the north side
and it's inevitable that distance makes
things hard it also makes the heart grow
fonder makes totally it totally does and
I it definitely makes them appreciate
each one more you know when they're kind
of being pulled apart and by going to
different schools so when they do get to
see each other it is really romantic and
passionate when you have to film those
more intimate scenes what is it like for
you as an actor to do that I feel like
it's very comfortable at this point I
mean I haven't done I mean it's the CW
you're not you're not getting too crazy
it's just like I mean hanging and
hugging that shower scene between yeah I
know that was definitely pretty spicy
but I haven't had to do that thus far I
mean I think we're all so comfortable
with one another that it's it's not even
really a thing we have a kissing scene
it's fine we don't really think about it
characters have to kiss it's a little
different and you're like wow okay
what's this but you know it's easy we're
all friends it would be more
nerve-wracking if you had to make out
with someone that you didn't know yeah
you know exact so it's by chance we do
end up like having to kiss each other
it's it's fine
weird plus you can call get along let me
get along cause you're doing pretty good
we're doing good
there aren't enough heart eye emojis in
the world to describe how adorable those
two are now moving on to hisses and
kisses kicking things off with hisses
penny Peabody oh my goodness girl I've
got to say I love the introduction of
this character but I'm so concerned that
this snake charmer has vicious
intentions hidden behind her sweet smile
so we're gonna see where that leads us
another hits of tonight the fact that
Miss Grundy's ex-husband supposedly has
an alibi
yeah no something is not adding up here
either with sheriff Keller or that like
fictitious alibi I'm not sure about that
but you guys comment with your thoughts
and you let me know and my last kiss of
the night
firing Smithers to to her mother's yeah
okay Hyrum I have a question for you
first of all how dare you
Smithers has done nothing to you except
for will look out for your daughter so
honestly I just don't know how I'm gonna
do I hope that Smithers is actually
doing okay but I'm thinking about your
man and I miss you every day moving on -
kisses yeah my first kiss of the night
is going out to black mailing Betty yes
when Betty confronted Cheryl in the
locker room I screamed with delight
truly I would watch an entire spin-off
of just Betty confronting Cheryl you're
stone-cold [ __ ] Betty Cooper the two of
them are just red-hot perfection loving
it another kiss of the night is the fact
that we got a Jughead and Veronica scene
we rarely get to see their friendship so
it was a really nice moment to highlight
that and I honestly hope that we're
gonna be seeing a lot more of that in
season two and my last and biggest Wow
kiss of the night is to the Pussycats
making their first debut in season two
and what is this oh hi Cheryl
Sharyl blossom join them for this
episode now I was so pumped to hear
their rendition of milkshake it has been
stuck in my head
for weeks now so I'm so excited you guys
finally got to hear it but I caught up
with Ashley Marie and Madeline Peck to
get the inside scoop on how that musical
moment was actually made take a look yes
so not bad the gorgeous cover of
milkshakes in episode 2 is so amazing to
be a literary pussycat that was so
amazing it was so much fun I have so
much fun with mad as it is it was so fun
it was actually super last minute I'm
ever getting a rewrite Roberto texted me
he's like you're joining the Pussycats
again it was like me it was super fun it
was definitely treacherous we were on
top of this roof and I was on like a
lion like a rope and I was terrified of
falling but I'm not afraid of heights it
was super fun it was like 3:30 in the
morning but we had a blast and it was
really cute the way that it plays out
how she's like well if you can come and
join you know the Dixons and I could be
a pussycat unlike candy though she can't
she did I learned the choreography like
20 minutes before I got up there but it
was super fun and it was it's always fun
grating pussycat some Josie it's got
such an amazing voice it's like a dream
come true what has it been like for you
joining the vixens though you know we
only have oh we've only been able to
touch her in a little bit yeah um so I
haven't been able to enjoy like the full
love of tiny shorts and pom-poms and
like clunky fat cloud sneakers but I
think it's gonna be great
you make it sound so glamorous no I like
totally oh that sounds so awful but I
always wanted to be a cheerleader so
this is a little a little dream
Jozy girl Congrats on making the mix-ins
I'm so excited for you
alright guys it's time to start hitting
the comments and tweeting me with your
top kisses and kisses of the episode and
also your latest mask man series now
I'll be back with you for our preview
show of chapter 16 the watcher in the
woods to discuss all your thoughts and
bring you scoop from the cast so give
this video a like and hit subscribe on e
t--'s youtube channel and I'll see you
next time for more Sweetwater secrets
bye guys
[Music]
you